welcome everybody to another YouTube
hangout super excited to be here I i am
joined with a special guest Laura
Wellington who is with thread mb and
asked me to do an interview for her
website and I said instead of just doing
a regular interview why don't we turn it
into a YouTube video hangout so you guys
could learn about cut mb and also hear
the answers to the question so Laura
welcome aboard oh my pleasure i'm
actually excited to interview you i'm a
big fan of what you're doing and i
actually tried to listen to a number of
least a few times a week if they are so
inspiration with great names and
excitement and insight into them as well
so very cool tell us a little bit about
thread and b and then whatever questions
you want to ask hit me up this is a
chance ok so thread and b is in ezine
that's what started about a year ago and
what we're doing over here is we're
combining interviews from the imams with
interviews from major celebrities across
the board whether it be an entertainment
media industry nonprofits of what we're
doing is you it's the gap between the
two and share or both are doing to
better the world not only through your
work causes that they have either
launched during volved in or or what not
do that it's just so much out there that
not only are the social media moms and
when i say that the mom bloggers the mom
blog or the youtube channel we trick
what they're doing what they're bringing
to this planet in the form of good is
incredible Bob festive and so are we
know this libraries that we're
interviewing they're all doing something
very interesting other in the world LT
in the back and the back end my personal
cause is helping those and their
children because I
widowed very uh for kids on my own and
so I know the chat on the thuggees we
also shed light on those challenges as
well as how we help them through a
corporate grant and we've been very
fortunate because we've grown very
quickly a lot a lot of interest and so
you don't only now highlight those me
your moms but we've invited her grace
bloggers who might not be moms or
bloggers or what not to also submit
their links in their websites and their
blogs for consideration although we do
that the limited basis and garnish
really is the social meaning and mom
world cool well I'm not a social media
mom but I'm looking forward to doing
some advice and feedback so let's get
into it what are your questions a first
question what is your personal mantra
and by that i mean the phrase that sort
of directs every choice and every the
direction your life is taken what is
that yeah for me it's on the wall right
behind me believe the subject of this
interview against to AH you know
honestly growing up I didn't know what
it was I didn't even know what a mantra
was I guess uh I believe for me it
breaks down as a couple components one
is to believe in yourself and that's the
most obvious answer I think most people
think about when I think about believe
self-confidence believe you know believe
you can do it believe in your abilities
for me it's also believing what you're
doing that you need to have a passion
for what you're doing I think too many
people are doing work whether it's a
business or a career because somebody
else told them to do it or somebody
else's expectations of them to do it
we're doing because our parents want us
to do it or our culture or you know
friends or it's the safe thing to do but
not necessarily the thing that we should
be doing and so you need to you need to
believe in what you're doing you need to
have passion for your work and if you
don't then
need to move on and trust that by doing
other things and exploring you'll find a
thing that makes you come alive and then
the last component to believe for me is
believing that it will work out that
when at the start it's failing and you
just see darkness around you and you
think this is a stupid idea having the
conviction to follow through that there
is light at the end of the tunnel and so
yeah for me it's all about believe it
came from my parents when I was in
school I didn't get fantastic grades I
got you know B's and C's which I guess
aren't that bad but you know the
expectation was to get a's and both my
sisters got a's and every report card
season my parents we'd have to have the
talk go to their bedroom and sit on the
bed and we talked about my grades and
and instead of you know attacking me or
harassing me it was much more building
up my confidence and telling me that i
was a ghost really carmichael my mom's
last name is cuz truly so I was like
australie Carmack and I could do
anything and I started to you know I
started we'll leave that not that's the
core belief for me I think it came to my
parents always instilled that you know
that sense of belief in myself that
whatever I put my mind to I could go and
accomplish and now I'm spreading that
for others that's one of the things that
I see in in your work and your videos is
obviously ah obviously I can improvise
messages it's it's all and I think
that's one of the hardest things that my
I audience winner there entities whether
it be a corporation or breathing like a
blog it's someone's going to want to be
in you know we're going to want to read
them weekly or daily or whatnot that's
it's tough for many people that don't
grow up and then [ __ ] you had the
confidence to go out and say yeah you
know I gotta stick with it yeah I think
even before yeah even though we're
thinking about other people thinking
that like I believe that I have
something more sharing
in creating the blog right like I
believe that I have a message that is
important where a lot of people don't
believe that they have a message that is
worth sharing so they can't even start
to thinking about what other people read
it or care about it because they they
haven't even tackled that first step
we're believing that hey like I have
something to say I have a life that that
has been meaningful and I can contribute
and get back to help others my story is
important well the story has to be begun
right and and along the way they're
going to be success is there going to be
failures and cookie not confidence in
two acts step along your path because he
I think we're all part of you there's a
journey here it's not just just I want
you to share with us what are some of
the things we've done in the past ask
that is sort of brought you to today and
it's her carved this new entity you can
share some of that sure I thought I
wanted to be a banker growing up with I
said I was gonna be a banker my high
school yearbook it says we're going to
be in ten years it's at VP at a bank I
didn't have entrepreneurial influences
really growing up my parents taught me
the foundation of believed and taught me
how to be a human being and you know a
decent human being that that I hope but
didn't teach me about business they were
not entrepreneurs you know my dad worked
for the government for a long time and
got his pension and my mother was a
lawyer and so I didn't really think
about certain the business until I got
to university and that's where I can hit
with two people who had started the
business and they had some success but
very limited and they asked me to join
as a as a third own or the company to
help them grow this thing up and I was
interested by the challenge but you know
wasn't sure that this is what I want to
do and it came down to crunch time where
the hardest decision I had to make in my
life was I was in my last year of
University and I had opportunities to
work at Merrill Lynch and McKinsey
Consulting
which would have been my dream job it's
like this is what I worked my whole life
you know I guess I'm on my whole life
but through high school and universities
like this is what I was working towards
here it is finally get the opportunity
and you know paying me 80
two-hundred-thousand-dollar starting
salary and fly me around the world and
put me up in the Waldorf Astoria just
for a job interview and like this life
that I had always pictured for myself it
was available to me meanwhile I was part
of this company that was struggling we
didn't know what we were doing I'm
making three hundred dollars a month we
weren't having success everything up to
that point when I tried and work I had
realized some success you know it wasn't
for lack of effort here I was trying and
nothing was happening and we weren't
getting any results and was just
soul-crushing and serious confidence
breaking and I had to decide do I go and
take this job that I always wanted or do
I continue on with this business that
isn't working clearly isn't working and
you know the smart safe easy decision
would have been to go to the job and my
friends all wanted those jobs and AH
just something inside of me felt like I
need to give this a shot I don't know
why but i need to you know what is I
didn't want to live with regret I didn't
want to look back on my life and say I
wish I had done that business I wish I
gave it more I wasn't through with it
yet and so I said you know the thing
that made it easier for myself and said
I get myself a year I'm gonna try this
for a year you know so my friends were
taking a year off and traveling and
doing whatever I said I'm gonna try this
business for a year doesn't work you
know mckinsey & Merrill Lynch may not be
there but but somebody else will be
there I can always get a job so I'm
going to get myself a year and
fortunately enough it worked out I
didn't have to go back and get a job i
turn the business around we ended up
building it up we got acquired a couple
years later but at the time like looking
back it said that was a no brainer super
easy decision but at the time was
insanely difficult and I didn't know
what to do and that has
since then become a mantra of mine to
thinking about will I regret not doing
this like I'm afraid of this well I
regret not doing it when I'm 80 looking
back in my life said man I should have
just should have done that thing and
even though it could be scary it's it's
feeling the fear and doing it anyway and
every time you exercised that muscle it
builds and grow stronger and it's easier
to say yes to things that may seem risky
or stupid or scary in the future and so
that was the heart that was the first
point for me that was the hardest one
and then every other one has just been
easier and easier and easier as it found
a lot because I think that um you cut
your teeth could use this level or the
next business if you don't cut your
teeth before you get there and then i
recall i can t you cut your teeth on
this other business and you found your
footing in it and so you know going
forward dear your end and the steering
mounted of time even if its judgment
call that skill alone has been so
valuable yeah I want to tell in a sense
of life or death mode where you're going
to eat or you're going to not being able
to make that judgment call is that the
value is I think that's one of the
things that you know my readers I need
to learn is that you know you gotta app
I gotta try it and in and risk failure
me you know and ya can't grow without
risk can't do it great is you risk later
risk but you know I've always believed
and I think you're proved today it's
less risky one with that but you're
betting on is yourself yeah I think
that's the best bit is that you can make
and I think yeah I think the challenge
for a lot of people is fighting the head
versus the heart and I believe that all
the big decisions
in life that you have to make her with
the heart and all the little ones are
with the head so the big decisions in
life are like who who should I marry
right who or what what job should I go
into our what business should I start
what what should my vocation be right
like those are big decisions that you
should make with your heart and often
the the logical answer like the linear
thinking answer the one that makes the
most sense is the one that's in direct
opposite to what you're feeling with the
heart so I can go and start a business
and that's maybe what I really want to
do and that's what's in my heart or I
could want to go marry that person
what's in my heart but everything on
paper is saying that's the wrong thing
to do what when everything is alive and
great it's easy right if you're having
your heart on the same page super easy
to make that position but it's when
they're not aligned when you're when the
logical smart thing to do is completely
against what you really really really
want to do those are the tough bets and
that's when you have to listen to your
art and do the thing that gets you
excited and risk failure risk it not
working out and and you know failure I
don't really see we see feelings is
super negative thing it's really just
feedback as to how to make it better the
next time like expect failure it's going
to happen you will know failure
everybody faces it if you have no
failure it means you've lived your life
so safe that you haven't done anything
with it so failure is not bad failure is
good you will fail your way to success
you'll fail fail fail fail then you will
succeed and so anytime you're caught
into a big decision I would always try
to if you can step out of it because we
often make excuses based out of fear
it's based out of fear that we call
practicality this is the practical thing
to do but really we're just afraid of
doing it and we talk ourselves down from
doing the thing that we really should be
going out and doing and so the answer is
not not to not be afraid you will be
afraid you'll be you might be terrified
it's likely the scariest thing you ever
do in your life it's to feel that fear
and do it anyway because you feel in
your heart that you are guided towards
doing
it's making you come alive you need to
at least explored until that feeling is
gone I used to have a personal side a
little quick story I went to Paris 11
year when I was in university I don't
think I've told this story before so
this is a new story I went to Paris one
year and I'm in University of a single
guy and I'm standing outside the Notre
Dame Cathedral and this girl comes up to
me and asked me for directions and I
thought you know I thought she was
really cute and I thought hey I should
ask her out or see what she's doing
tonight and and I was worried that my
French was a good enough friend you know
all like these limiting beliefs come in
and I ended up like chickening out and
not I'm not asking her anything and just
gave her directions where she needs to
go because I had the map and then she
you know walked away and I got so upset
with myself that Italy's try right to
like to this day still think back on
that moment like it's an entire it's 20
years of regret for not taking action
and so I took a picture of like the path
that she was walking it just shows like
this bridge scene and they not putting
that on my wall at home as just as a
reminder that don't let opportunities
walk away from you right and and just
when those things happen to embrace the
fear and risk the rejection and risk the
failure because if worst case she says
no great I move on to something else but
what happened was I didn't say anything
and now 20 years later I'm still
thinking and talking about it now I'm
happily married you know I'm not that
that super worried about it but just
like just taking that picture and put it
up on the wall uh was a good reminder
for me to win you feel that fear don't
don't talk yourself down from doing the
thing you should do because it's it's a
practical smart thing to do just try and
try to live life without any regrets no
that's a great lead-in to me Ewing uh
over there through the videos and
through the various other let's say that
you do says though I
came across believe you know in building
my company I was you know I'm a big
runner and so I I listened to a number
for the videos while I'm running because
they are and and every even if your pan
or would you you still have moments when
you question yourself I mean we're only
human um to learn from other people and
to hear good at wisdom so what not from
from mothers that are doing their own
thing and doing while I bet or hear it
to failure I've gone on through the
lessons or continue to go through
lessons it is invaluable and so your V
you feature to everybody from tony
robbins to i actually mean it's
limitless I just think of how many ARMs
this is one of my favorites but um let's
share eight readers what are you doing
that will help them in what is it let's
believe about sure I guess in a context
of but the youtube channel I started it
as a way to give back to people who were
asking questions I started it as a way
to people are writing to me with
questions about running the business
after I had sold my company had some
success and i would spend 30 40 minutes
responding each email this time and I
realized that's not scalable right like
I'm on it's a huge flattery that people
would want my opinion and what they
should do with their life and then I
realized as more came in like I can't
how many hours in a day if it takes me
half an hour to write each email I'm
gonna be tapped out pretty quickly so
that I make videos on it and I would
answer that person's question and then
hopefully other people who had the same
question could benefit from the answer
as well and I kind of wished i had
people to be able to ask questions to
when i was struggling in that mode the
channel has evolved to the point where
one of the things you talked about
earlier on in this session was about
environment and how important your
environment is to build yourself up and
i felt a little bit complacent like
comfortable you know
like I achieved more than what my
friends had achieved my parents were
proud of me regardless of what I do and
I didn't have anybody in my life saying
listen what you're doing is great well
you should be up here like you've done a
lot but you're still playing a small
again you should be way higher but I
didn't have anybody telling me that I
had bunch people telling you why you're
doing so well congratulations i wish i
could do that and it's hot like again
super humbling is a amazing problem to
have i'm not complaining but i also
believe that if you are capable of doing
more that you should and i believe a lot
of your readers are capable of doing a
lot more than what they're currently
putting out as their effort and so for
me it comes down to the environment your
habits your routines the videos you
watch the habits that you have so like
if you're running and you're filling
your head with knowledge every time you
come back pumped ready to go ready to
tackle on the day and i found that too
many entrepreneurs you know myself
included would happen to come across an
interview and happen to get inspired
that day maybe you maybe you read a post
on your blog and that like fires me up
or maybe you listen to tony robbins and
it just you happen to come across it and
it's you know what time is it you know
to 30 here almost on the East Coast and
that that's set you up for the rest of
the day I didn't you start the next day
and it's it's poof like it's gone what
happened to that crazy driver energy had
the day before at least at least for me
and so I needed to have something every
day to start my day with intention with
the drive to learn from people who've
done a lot more and the more you
surround yourself with these people like
I'm never going to meet Steve Jobs or
Walt Disney or you know a lot of these
people who passed on but by hanging
around them a little bit more
consistently every day watching their
videos I hope that a little bit of their
magic pixie dust rubs off on me and I
start to challenge myself a little bit
more and I start to dream bigger and I
start to believe that I can do it and I
start to want to build a team and create
more than what I've created to this
point and so I created most of the
videos now they're on the channel
selfishly for me like I want this I need
this in my life consistently because I
want to grow more than
I'm at right now and and I shared that
with the community and thankfully people
like it right like you're downloading it
and watching it when you run lots of
great comments we got people watching
live for loving the videos too and it's
it's an honor that it can have such an
impact on other people's lives I would
still be making these videos for myself
because I need it I wish I also didn't
have to make them I wish somebody else
had done the work I had the bill I'm six
people who work on these videos with me
now I had to build a team around this or
I just wanted to be a consumer and
nobody else had done the work so if i
wanted to make if I want to learn from
elon musk I don't want to be the guy
sitting through 30 hours of research of
videos watching his interviews I want to
be lickin suet in 10 minutes his best
stuff nobody else is doing it so that ok
I'm going to do it because I need it for
me i'ma turn into a business so I said
you know what I tell you what I am glad
you're doing it because this world
really needs it and you start my
mornings and in such a positive way you
know um I think you make people very
thoughtful about their lot of people
that you featured and um and I think
that I'm more we flew a bit more pushing
sometimes and you know um you know I can
it my desire because I was very young
and lost my husband to cancer and I'd
for little kids to raise and figure out
what the next step in life was and and
um I paint um I say I'm privileged and
that became my attitude it's the one the
[ __ ] hi um but at the moment where you
just sort of need help you know you need
you Wiz dykes you need you need that
little bit of positive outlook
you know everyone has a story and
everyone has lived you know um a life
that and you put that into 10 points or
or you know a few of them and it makes a
difference and so I'm glad you're doing
it because you know I've it available to
us if you didn't I'm admitted to relay
some thing with you hopefully after this
interview you know all right hey well um
oh you're good yes I think it's
definitely with the time yeah well I
appreciate it yes I wasn't private
social causes at fiji him um I to
believe is there like a specific social
cause that you are involved in and if
the air is why yeah my social cause is
helping entrepreneurs I think I think
entrepreneurs will solve all the
problems of the world I think
entrepreneurs will solve wars
entrepreneurs will solve diseases
entrepreneurs will solve everything all
all the creativity all the new things
that come out in the world are by
entrepreneurs you don't see a ton of
innovation from big companies I don't
expect my government or governments of
the world to you know be on the
forefront of new cutting-edge things
everybody's learning from entrepreneurs
and so I believe that what I'm doing is
a huge social cause helping all the
social causes that on top of trying to
create more awareness and understanding
when I first started the chain on doing
a lot of videos of famous entrepreneurs
for me I don't think that you want to be
the next anybody like I don't want to be
the next Steve Jobs or the next bill
Gates next one I'm Buffett I want to be
the best Evan Carmichael and you should
be the best lower you know Wellington
and everybody should be the best version
of themselves and you can pull pieces
from different people and you can pull
something like you may
eight Donald Trump but you can pull
something from Donald Trump to make you
better you may hate Kanye West we can
pull so from him to make you better I
you know you might love Oprah and
there's a ton that you can learn from
her to make you better and your goal
shouldn't be the beat the next Oprah but
you to be the best version of you and
what I found that super interesting is
by some of the people that we've
profiled we've changed opinions of a lot
of people so as an example you know we
had we profile a number of black
entrepreneurs and for me as long as
there's advice to share I'm totally I'm
okay with it like I'm totally cool i
love profoundly different people I don't
see color and and people we've had some
people in the comments say you know I
grew up and my parents always told me
that black people were fill in the blank
of all these things that they couldn't
do and like now watching this video and
seeing these great people has totally
changed changed my perspective so we've
turned this guy grew up in like a
extremely racist environment into now
somebody who's more tolerant and
accepting and I've never met the guy
right he's just watched some of my
videos and that happens all the time for
all sorts of so people have this picture
of like I can't be like this because I
am this like I can't be successful
because I'm a woman or I can't be
successful because I'm an immigrant or
whatever is I'm disabled or I live in
the wrong country or fill in the blank I
can't be successful and then I'm making
videos showing people who are successful
who come from worse upbringing than what
you came from and they made it happen
and it it changes the mindset changes
the belief system now the story that the
tell themselves starts to change oh
maybe it is possible and so I see that
as the for me the greatest possible
social good that I could be doing and
leveraging what what I'm talented at and
yeah back to the point I believe all the
world's problems can be solved by
entrepreneurs and that's part of our
mission is to help them do it I think
that's great i think i agree with you
very much so
and you know which it disheartened to me
though that at the creativity that is
required to be an entrepreneur doesn't
it isn't mentored no system as much as
possible and I think that we do or
ourselves were housed in the foot by not
doing that and our exact out or just not
supporting it in our schools yeah I
don't think education system is set up
for entrepreneurship I remember you know
so going through school other nothing
about entrepreneurship I had one class
in my fourth year university course i
did a batch of commerce at university of
toronto which is the most respected
university in canada and amongst their
in the world and one class on small
business management and it was it was a
joke like i was really running my
company I you know the level of
knowledge of my peers of the businesses
that they wanted to start with so
rudimentary because then we didn't have
the they're bringing I think it's
starting to change I think people are
seen success of of entrepreneurs and
young entrepreneurs and seen it as more
and more of them and people making a
success of themselves at a young age the
more people see that the more they have
role models to look up to and they're
doing it on their own like don't blame
the education system don't blame your
parents you know do it find a reason
right like now that's not say we can't
make the education system better we
can't provide more training we can't
provide more mentorship but also let's
not use that as a crutch to say hey if
you got a dream you find a way that's
what entrepreneurs do we find a way to
make it happen regardless of this you
know support that we have is being
creative with what we do have instead of
blaming what we don't what I thing that
I'm looking into if you have sister
drive to be entrepreneur you have a
larger a larger reason the widget or
something I think that that alone will
drive you insane until you actually
follow through and you know and now with
the world being so close next so to
speak with
um you know all of the virtual ability
to contact and learn from various people
are seeing more cases you know in other
words to what used to be the case
studying we're seeing that every day
because we're ever seeing it in you know
and very is for our fatness it has
become the school of the entrepreneur
what we're seeing online and what you
know and i think more entrepreneurs are
coming out and they're you know they're
coming inside a classroom but they're
not in the classroom because they are in
front of her sure I mean for me growing
up I'm I'm 36 so I'm not super old but
not super young either though uh when I
was going through elementary in high
school we learned from books like the
internet was just coming as I was
graduating high school uh you know I
remember going to the library and
pulling out books and what's interesting
is now I get teachers writing to me
saying I play your videos every day in
my class because I want my students to
learn and I've helped some teachers
build lesson plans around the content
that we have so they can try to help
spread that knowledge i wish i had
youtube as a high school that like I
wish my channel existed for me like the
high school version of me that I could
look up to and learn from it's never
been easier to get access to the
knowledge to the information to the
wisdom to the motivation it's never been
easier I you know all you need is access
to the internet and you can get that for
free at a library at McDonald's sitting
outside a starbucks you know you can get
that for free so you got to spend your
time wisely to make sure that you invest
in yourself so very Yost question and
we're good yeah oh wait no um how do you
want to be remembered um I don't know I
don't think about my legacy that much
maybe I should maybe as i get older
that'll be something somebody wrote in
the comments I look like I'm 30 he's
surprised in 36 what year is it yes I'm
turn 36 may I don't remember I don't
know uh you know a lot of the stuff that
I do I guess is so outwardly focused
like I would love for entrepreneurs to
take the wisdom and apply it and I love
seeing them come alive and use the
knowledge and something good that I
don't have a goal for myself as to like
I want people to say this about me when
i'm gone i don't know i guess be
remembered for making an impact changing
people's lives but it's not something
that I kind of it doesn't it doesn't
impact the work that I do right i like
it i don't wake up saying i need to be
remembered for this so i'm going to do
that but I'm driven by impact like I
want to impact people's lives I want to
do it on a bigger scale I'm super
grateful for what I've accomplished so
far but I'm also equally I don't wanna
say stressed more like ambitious to go
out and do more like if everything fell
away right now be super grateful for
everything that's happened in my life
but also feel like I want I need to do
more I need to have a bigger impact so I
want to be remembered as someone who
made an impact there we go perfect for
you I think if everything from my wife
tomorrow morning I can't even imagine
what that morning would look like get
out of the way as Evan would be on a new
bag that like a hundred miles per hour
for sure okay your book yes where we
have in the book is coming out backed it
with your are away in that the book so
the book is coming out december six uh I
haven't released a title or what it's
about yet but I do have a blog series
that every week I update people on how
the books coming along as well as answer
questions and more like a business
behind the scenes look at what it takes
to get a book with a major book
publisher a penguin Random House
published what goes into it what I'm
facing each week and so every Monday now
one day at noon eastern I believe a
video comes out talking about kind of
book update so yeah december six is the
launch date we are in the final stages
of the editing in approvals and all that
stuff and I'm itching to there's a lot
of bureaucracy involved in writing the
book way more than I ever expected and I
was told that there was a lot but it's
even crazier than I expected because I'm
tremors you want it now right like I
will will something into existence
because I wanted to happen and that's
that's what we do as entrepreneurs and
it's been a year I figure how many
videos we have almost a year I think of
making videos talking about the book and
we still have until December before that
she comes up so people in the comments
are saying why december six so long I
know I feel your pain this is this is
the publishing world it's it's broken it
is broken but yes that's the plan run
hey now it's okay so there are a lot of
my readers are also writers obviously so
others and whatnot and I know that they
know your pain out that wanna be so
follow his series because you I'm sure
you'll learn a few things about it and
it's not an entrepreneur and full but
alright so I think we're good as what we
could go on with this conversation
forever um nothing that but um it was
really really wonderful meeting you and
learning from you and and really
appreciate what you're doing up there
and it lists to keep hopefully many of
my readers will uh so thanks Evan I love
it and for everybody watching live and
watching the repeat I I've left a link
to Laura's a website thread and be in
the description you can go check her out
see what she's up to thank you guys so
much for watching thank you laura for
the time continue to believe
everyone and we'll see you soon